all right welcome everyone to another
episode of play watch listen which is a
monthly podcast where we talk about all
the gaming things and other media things
that have happened in a month it's
called that because we work in different
facets of the games industry way you can
either play watch or listen to things
that we have created how's everyone
doing good sweet Mike's doing well
nominally well compared to recent events
but both of you guys awesome they're
fairly well you haven't been sick or
anything have you dude no no we have
maintained our fitness sadly our you
know comrades here nearly fallen it
seems recently very going true might not
Mike had like some GUI talk do you want
to talk about that or not share the
photo I showed you to embarrass and be a
my face inflated on one side too quite
scary proportions well yeah like that
inspire you you're like oh yeah this
experience it was so it was actually
genuinely weird like being for like a
couple of days someone that nobody could
help but stare at when I walk down the
street like that was actually genuinely
an interesting experience but like I
know it's helping me help me with the
empathy of people who have to put up
with that every day that's I was a weird
experience true well Alana yeah I'm
holding in there I'm alive doing okay
yeah I heard we just you've been through
some [ __ ] in the last week and have been
on a bunch of painkillers so we have to
delay this because I was vomiting a lot
it's been yeah sorry you like right
after you were you were you were doing
poorly as our two non-american friends
would say and you are still you're there
for that charity stream yeah probably
should probably shouldn't have done that
to be honest because then I spent the
whole next day yeah someone said yeah I
saw you once and you look like you
really didn't want to be that I'm like
I'm gonna be honest I didn't I didn't
but like I was trying very hard to hold
it in for Australia did my best but this
is a show what we also talked about
the things we've experienced in a month
and I mentioned to see you guys if
anyone would like to take the room to
talk about Star Wars we can do that
because we have judges topic this
podcast has become you know Star Wars
and miscellaneous other things it's
funny because I I was having dinner with
them with with JJ but it's a name drop
he's not coming who's a friend a game
game director on a thing I'm working on
and we were and he's not really into
Star Wars that much and I was like it's
not I don't want to sound like one of
those fans and then I proceeded to have
this laundry list of all the things and
he was like you need to just accept that
you are one of those fans and and I I
think he may have he may have impressed
upon me that I am because it's like I
looked at it through the lens of all
this 40 years worth of Star Wars fandom
and I was like what are they doing
there's there are they are asleep at the
wheel on this thing and I shouldn't care
but I have a hard time not just being
very frustrated I think there are like
two sides to that where I'm I feel very
similarly in it I I don't feel like I've
been able to enjoy the new trilogy very
much by virtue of caring about previous
Star Wars stuff however I just keep
sticking to but I'm also okay with other
people enjoying this and I'm not going
to argue with them if they enjoy it so
it's like that's the difference to me
and that's okay and other people are
allowed to like it this is a new thing
that they get to experience Star Wars
through and if they like that I'm cool
with it and I think that makes you not
one of those Star Wars fans even if
sometimes it takes out of it then you're
alright Mike I well I say I think I said
this in the last one like I'm not
convinced I'm actually a Star Wars fan
cuz I love it sent me there
I loved last Jedi a lot because of all
the stuff it did that felt like it was
expanding the opportunities story-wise
in the universe the story was telling I
like something
characters and introduce it that felt
like finally like a Star Wars that kind
of surprised and interested me and then
obviously this new movie just completely
kind of undoes a lot of the stuff that
was specifically was interesting to me
fanatically about the second film so for
me it's like it's one of those things
where it's just like you know what like
I'm not going to agree with the audience
about this I'm definitely not like I'm
definitely I know I'm off the mainstream
I did love on Mandalorian and some are
the mainstream I think that most people
like lost Jedi it seems like they don't
but I actually think majority of people
do I did a Twitter poll which is
obviously not a very good survey that's
it was very surprised that he was I
think 70% of people said yes to liking
the lost Jedi and I expected it to be
more like 6040 but I I feel like maybe
we have a warped view and most people do
like oh I think I think in 2020 we all
will have walked fear I feel like that
hits on exactly my impression of that I
feel like this was 100% there was no way
that we weren't going to have the
outcome that we did with with Star Wars
this the last three given our current
climate just because we are a culture
right now that are unabashedly
extremists on both sides right people
either love it or hate it no one is
really centrist about anything why would
this be any different so I don't think
that anyone's gonna be like I was you
know it's kind of it was okay people
could be like this is the best [ __ ]
installment of this franchise ever and
you're wrong if you disagree with me
pick a song
yeah pick a side exactly so I feel like
it was the most interesting thing to me
about Star Wars is not like you if I
want to we can sit here and break down a
new hope and Empire and in return the
Jedi already
no you are but to me it was more of a
boo this is interesting sit back and
watch and see how these this thing right
here which which spans now three
generations right or potentially more
but I mean for sure there's three
generations of people that have
experienced this and just as everything
else on our climate is kind of spanning
those thing with three generations the
Boomers the Gen Xers and the Millennials
we get to see how those three people
look at the same thing essentially from
three different angles and that to me
was the most thing I sat and and
Collider was cool and invited us to a
screening we get to sit back we're in
super comfy chairs and it's a huge
screen everyone's there with lightsabers
and they've gave us you know little
Funko pops it was a great little party
and I just let it wash over me just like
I did with last Jedi I could break it
down and there was even moments when I
was giggling because it felt like
everyone's going yeah yeah I know it's
really really meaningful in cinema we
got to wrap this thing up and it was so
just shrink-wrapped in the spectacle
that was like sure a man a jacksepticeye
- ah mclaughlin of dear friend I said
what did you think and I said man I went
into it like I do with when you're
boarding a plane that's that you know is
gonna have turbulence you know you're in
for a bumpy ride but at the end of the
day you're just glad to be on the ground
and off the plane and that's how I
thought about this last thought
heartbreak bad it wasn't awful it wasn't
terrible he didn't do the thing and
injustice it was just fine it was great
and we could point out all the
disparities and flaws in it but it was
fine it was a great movie I enjoyed I
had the perfect experience I was sat
between I was sat with with my girl
overfed and she we'd on one side I on my
right I remember this on my right was a
grandmother there with like a grandchild
I was loving every second and and
explaining all the backstory this kid
had never clearly never seen like the
older Star Wars movie so it's like oh
and that's that's the person who did
that and and having just this amazing
Star Wars fan experience and on my
left was a guy of I guess roughly the
same age and his wife and he was audibly
laughing at the movie and every point
and I was just I was just sat there and
I just got to experience the film
through both of those people and to the
extent that at one point the the the
ground my neck swooped and I kind of
like made eye contact with her we kind
of high-fived over something and then
the and then I laughs I the guy laughed
to my left and that's very rare in a
British cinema yourself this is a movie
this is what happened on my left so so
he so I can't remember which moment it
was but he laughed a particularly like
ridiculous moment in the play I think it
was when they were onto like their fifth
different key to a lock to work out
where they were going and he openly loft
and then I kind of I looked over and
like acknowledged him laughing and I and
his his his wife kind of who was sat
between us kind of lent into and then
you're ruining this film for that guy
next to us but it was and throughout
then the rest of film me and him were
laughing me and the ground were weeping
it's just a lovely experience for me
kind of seen both sides of that was like
watching it was like what's the name of
the two the two one the two critics in
the Muppets it was like seeing between
them watching it and it was great and at
this point I had a power outage sorry
ladies and gentlemen so I lost a chunk
of the podcast here
because there was context that is gone
so now that the conversation makes sense
so we're gonna jump ahead to when I got
power back you missed them talking about
ready player one and at one point Troy
went on a bit of a tirade about demons
and preparing for the coronavirus all
right now you're all caught up my
thought was like if the coronavirus were
like just spread like wildfire would it
take the 405 or the five because that
means either Austin gets it first or I
do
that's an LA joke everybody there you go
does walk that way because I think it is
like very contact base the least
resistance I don't think it's just
airborne so you
is gonna spread in a certain direction
what's it called the ah what is interest
as a research this for um we did a game
for quarantine circular which was about
disease control and there there is like
essentially this than one number is the
only number that matters which is how
many people get sick from the last
person if that number is below one the
disease will disappear if it's heading
towards two or three the entire world's
gonna die in minutes and it's kind of
there's a there's a really interesting
kind of variation just like one point
whatever and that's the transmission but
yeah it's always very local and you use
it of true sorry I'm just and very
boring I notice a long is gone while
I've been doing it all yourself yeah I
don't know what's happening I feel like
maybe it is the corona virus it's in the
walls now we'll see anyway no
counterpoint Mike I find games that are
specifically about plagues always very
good like I've loved every single one I
played like play gank absolutely love it
well you don't play quarantine circular
yet so maybe they'll change the tredstep
to that one yeah Mike Bethel I have a
question that is the not obsession but
what is the the common employment of the
term circular within your games what is
what is the purpose of oh it was just an
idea we had we so subservice circular
I'm gonna try and keep this really short
because obviously I don't just promo my
work but you know all of this is
available on Steam and switch it's worth
mentioning so subsurface killer was like
just this filler job basically we had we
got we had a project that was just kind
of starting production and then the
publisher we were working with kind of
backed out because they had a management
to farfel so they backed out so the
whole project was kind of cancelled a
few months in but we decide hiring
people so I had all these really
talented people in a room and we had you
know dwindling resources should we say
and we basically worked out what's the
how long can we actually make a game
before we can make a game for five
months okay what can we make in five
months that was what subsurface circle
was it was never really was meant to
make its money back and essentially keep
the team
together while we figured out what was
next and then obviously self circular
did really well so we then but then we
all then we side the John wick kind of
negotiation but film negotiations take
months so we make quarantine circular
while we were negotiating the John wick
contract so they kind of both were
filler projects to answer your question
self-service circle is called
self-service circular just because that
was a good name for the game it's based
on a train line so and train lines
called stop service circular and then we
just like make Quarantine circular we
were like [ __ ] we didn't really think
about franchise here
I guess we'll we can't call everything
subsurface something that's ridiculous I
guess it's something circular is gonna
be the name of every single game in this
franchise so that's that's like final
fantasy right like out of fantasy the
reason why they got that name was
because it literally was the this the
last game we're gonna make guys cuz
we're about to go under so it's like the
last one who ships the game please turn
out the lights that went well
and yeah and that I think not that you
can never plan for these situations but
I think there's something really
interesting that happens creatively when
you are basically going well we're
screwed guys let's just do what we want
to do and and weirdly that can adobe you
should ever like artificially
manufacture that situation obviously but
I think interesting stuff can come about
when everyone in the room is just going
for it and doesn't expire yeah there
there was something cause of it
obviously when we were making last and
most of all was talking drill going in
the background so or something I have
the most I mean it's almost as if
they're psychic gardeners choose to come
I swear they're like waiting around the
corner going now's a good time yeah
that's gotta come that's that's that
level of plants that Troy hasn't yeah
you have to bring drill but it's a
beautiful [ __ ] car because we know
the elephant is a house
the topiary and of course no matter how
many this happens every Wednesday but no
matter how many times has happened an
eight-bit is now eight years old it
still is like I don't know if he wants
to help any but whatever it is I say we
own this band warts and all you guys are
here my gardeners outside and my dog
just losing his god no this is mine this
is real life
this is real life if you can't find a
way people are like well just pick him
up and hold him I was like you would see
I'm just gonna I'm just gonna hopefully
tire himself out but when we were making
last of us everyone of course was
talking about a kiss what he can do for
the franchise where you gonna do for the
sequel because you know Naughty Dog does
big franchises and Sony really likes big
ip's so how are you gonna build upon
this and well we can't do that yet we
want to save that for the sequel and the
ill and Bruce were just like this we're
treating this like this is the only game
we're ever gonna make if this is the
last game we make then this is what
we're gonna surprise me if that game was
written with a sequel in mind it sounds
like it is but it's such a cohesive like
I don't know near perfect story like it
ends one of my favorite video game
endings ever that if they were like now
I gotta say that for the sequel it does
not show they mail and III would agree
and I I didn't know for the longest time
this is a true story I didn't know for
the longest time if we were gonna do a
sequel and it wasn't until we were at we
were in London at this trashy bar on the
east side in London for and Neil and I
were enough drinks and to where we could
finally just like relax because we had
just they had hauled off all of the all
the awards and he goes so I've got an
idea for the secret [ __ ] you
serious so it was it was really that was
the first moment and then how much that
idea changed - it evolved but that also
sounds like it speaks to you know if
you're if you're there
for the BAFTAs or whatever it was that
sounds like you know obviously the game
has been out and shipped for you know
the better part of a year and if it's
like now I'm starting to think where
this could go that that is definitely
what Ilana was saying of let's just ship
it as this standalone entity and then if
the idea strikes because I'd like to
believe in my fantasy if he hadn't had
that thought if he hadn't said like oh I
know where to take this story and where
these characters need to go and blah
blah blah that it would be like we're
not gonna do one we're just not there
isn't gonna be a sequel like that we
can't force it you know they just no
matter how successful it was or whatever
unless the idea organically demands it
I don't know that's true I want to
believe that's true because I'm with a
lot of on it like it worked so well in a
way that it's like if first here there's
going to be a sequel and you're like oh
man but then you remember how much you
loved it anything media reaction was
like oh you're making a sequel to a
perfect ending and then I was like if
anyone can do it they care yeah but
they've earned the right to do that
right with the quality of the work
they've done like that's that's an
amazing to be able to make a decision
like that in-house like that's yeah
don't underestimate how much how few
people in their position have that power
and make sure can you think of another
game that on the flip side you're like
they shouldn't have done a sequel like I
love this as as a standalone thing I
wish I wish they had just done the first
one for some reason for me and I don't
want to knock it too much but Max Payne
like the fall of I didn't need the fall
of Max Payne it Max Payne 2 I didn't
need that one just max the play because
I didn't like Max Payne 2 Max Payne to
me is just still such a perfect game
actually want to play it on our show
because I I think Nolan would really
really enjoy especially finally
cryingbaby level it's just the best but
it's amazing seeing the world catch up
to remedies kind of ideas and tastes
like when that came out all of that twin
peaks' stuff all of that kind of weird
psychological stuff was
so have our God and strangely feels like
control was that moment where the world
caught up with them and I love that
realize how good they are yeah basically
I mean I think that really was the case
right they yeah they didn't change they
were making these great games throughout
but then I feel like the world got ready
for that
yeah exists I have a weird relationship
with sequels in general like it's easy
for me to talk about that when it comes
to TV where if I don't want a second
season of something because I don't feel
like it should exists and I feel it it
exists because of money I just won't
watch it so I just stopped watching
worse world after season one because I
was like this is such a concise story
I'm not doing it doesn't have season two
everyone's like no no more seasons and
I'm like thank God no more I was so
excited and Deadly Premonition is my
favorite game and when the premonition
to got announced so many people were
like oh my god Ilana you must be so
excited and I was like honestly like I'm
I am interested but excited is not the
right word because I don't need more of
that game because I love won that game
does so in no way am I like yes give me
more of the same thing because if it if
it's a story that wraps itself up really
neatly I feel like sometimes it just
dilutes it I wish we got less sequels in
general I mean I loved assassin's
creed's so much through two and
Brotherhood and then everything after
that kind of just fell apart for me and
I'm still bitter about it what a great
setup for us and I'm giving my credit
for this that British TV seems to have a
very good I'm responsible for you I
think that's probably why we think that
way he's like you don't have to keep
making seasons stop look at fleabag
fleabag was perfect like here's the
story by yeah I never I remember I
remember one of my first kind of
realizations of that was the office
because I watched the American one but I
was always kind of in parallel a fan of
Ricky Gervais is I just hadn't watched
the British show and it blew my mind you
know
American ones on for like eight seasons
or something and then I go in the
British office is like 14 episodes the
hooded whole thing and I just thought I
thought this is held up as fully equal
to a show that has like 20 times more
episodes as it and you watch it and it
like it blows you away it's such it's
such a I think that it's amazing and it
made me realize like bringing Gervaise
is a serious performer beyond beyond a
comedian and writer or whatever but like
the acting is weirdly intensely nuanced
and I don't think he had a lot of acting
experience before he did that character
know he played some war comes in like
other British sitcoms okay a show called
not be was it the 11 o'clock not the 9
o'clock news or not 11 o'clock
something like that and they were he was
in spaced as well which was and which is
another yeah
playing his David Brent character oh no
way basically it was something I think
it was a character he'd been playing
with for a while and they they brought
him in to do that a lot of aggressive
gardening going on back there my wife
cams not working everything's falling
apart you guys still here the the dog
fighting the garden commuting it I'm
doing like a mute record we hear it in
your recording we can just is going
through it yeah never mind I was trying
to be all kinds insult your amazing
voice-over capabilities try be
incredibly honest as they we know were
front door dealing with national hair
it's fine I could ask each of you the
question of you know people talk about
sequels all the time I feel like this is
relatively well known but for anyone
listening who doesn't know is like why
is it so much easier to get a sequel
Greenland why is that why does that seem
to be the case in the games industry why
does that seem to be the case in in film
and TV minimization of risk always is it
just because people know the name it's a
known quite well no no it's not about
them knowing the name it's that the it's
a known quantity in terms of its
predictable in terms of how successful
will thing be the the biggest thing when
you're trying to get money from a
publisher or a platf
holder or whatever is always how they
always you know you need to predict with
how will this do what's the best this
could do what's the worst this could do
and the simple thing is with a sequel
the the band the range of possibility is
shrunk because you know okay you know
West world was very popular but it
didn't hit anywhere near as big as Game
of Thrones so we know we're not gonna
with a sequel gallop to Game of Thrones
but we also know that West was populous
so we know we'll hear at least a certain
amount that's true games as well you
know we all know there's game developers
I know this I know the sales of every
game we've ever made I know how they did
I know how those how those sales trended
so like for example Thomas was alone
still sells amazingly now it's just one
of those evergreen things that's just
gonna continue to hopefully do ok
forever so I can go to a publisher and
go we should make Thomas was alone to
Thomas was alone harder and I can show
that that data and they'll know ok that
we're not gonna Thomas was alone is
never gonna be Mario but at least it's
not going to flop so there's a there's a
minimization of risk there but then you
have other with with platform holders
and publishers sometimes they want to
take a risk because if they can take a
risk on something new that might be
bigger than Call of Duty that's exciting
to them so it depends as well what the
intention is what you'll often find is
they have kind of with one publisher or
one film studio one whatever they'll
have like the safe bets that they know
are propping up their year and then
they're gonna take some of those wild
ones so like was Sony for example like
no man's sky could have absolutely
bombed could have been the biggest game
ever was pretty damn big but I'm sure if
we went back and looked through the date
I bet there was a the third installment
in a big triple-a franchise came out
within six months of it because that's
where their security is and then they're
trying the way they're things as well
and exercise our sink or swim so it's a
kind of litigation thing yeah I don't
know if that's true I might be talking
about since but whenever I talk to
people yeah
sequels generally a risk mitigation sry
i can't donate that is there else having
a different take on that I was gonna add
to that was like but and this is not to
disparage Bend or the game or anybody
who worked on it
but the the pitch for days gone how can
that fail it's like oh we're gonna do
Walking Dead meets Sons of Anarchy and
you're like well that's chocolate and
peanut butter put that in a videogame
that's awesome why would that not work
so but it didn't finally right like I
know it had mixed reviews but it
actually made quite a decent amount
money I believe didn't oh I don't know I
I think it I think it I think it did
later but I think it underperformed
leading up to it probably much more
exotic to the UK audience that's true
that's true sure that's that's that's
definitely a slice of America cutting
but my point holds that that was a new
IP and I think he came out within about
six months of God of War right yeah yeah
it was I think it came up before didn't
it today all the days gone it also got
pushed and pushed and pushed him first
row which I think that what happens is
that that disparity between announced
and launched there's such a short fuse
on that that people for some reason oh
[ __ ] we can talk about this what we were
using to talk about games that slip for
some reason there is this stigma of it's
not good because if we've pushed there's
something wrong with it they need to fix
it maybe it's not going to be as good as
I want so I think that there's this
common mentality that for some reason if
a game says there's a disappointment to
it when someone goes we're going to push
like when we'd announced we're gonna
push the last of us and they were they
were hell-bent on not doing that because
they did it the first time but the
reality the nature of the game was such
is like look we can either ship the game
as it is right now and it's not good or
week it's been a little bit more time
polishing it and be more proud of the
game we want but because people knew
this is when it was supposed to come out
and now it's gonna be later there's this
shift in the mentality of maybe it's not
going to be perfect and I think that
that kind of hurt Bay's gone as well to
new IP it's it's falling in the shadow
of of the last of us and it pushed and
pushed him
maybe the same thing with des training
too I mean I don't know if Ilana if you
felt that way this kind of speaks really
within your purview do you when days
gone was revealed that III I remember
seeing the footage and you know I was on
the post show for that for IGN it was
like I have no interest in this game and
people were angry at me because people
like Sony PlayStation did that their
presentations being exciting it I mean
to me it was just a another open-world
zombie game and I didn't see enough that
was different about it and then the
thing that they very much honed in on
being different about it was bikes which
is something that I am not particularly
interested in so that was my take on at
least which is very personal clearly I
know there well what people who were
excited about it but it just never
grabbed me as being different enough and
I do think that game was probably also
hurt by the Pacific Northwest setting
being the same as The Last of Us which
everyone was already extremely excited
about and like whether they like it or
not both being PlayStation products
people are automatically gonna
competitive frankly they do it anyway
but it just meant that yeah that game
that game never grabbed me and then you
know I tried it and I generally just the
same thing stayed true I just didn't
find it interesting and when it comes to
delays I think one very interesting
thing is this misconception that I don't
get is every game is always broken
so before a game ships like every game I
have ever seen they're always all broken
you just really right up until the point
that they're functioning like they're
amazing that we surface long enough for
actual release just all the time they're
all broken so to say like oh it's
delayed because it's bad it's like if
you don't understand how bad games are
till you see them they're all falling
about even a few months before release
that's a I think that's what's hilarious
about like yeah I think if anyone
actually saw what the average game
looked like a few months before it came
out it would terrify yeah they're
stitched up duct anton's the nation felt
like a door because
and ultimately doesn't matter because if
it runs and it's not breaking down too
much it's fine you know it's well and as
like even uncharted for push her
approved and I think Spiderman was the
same way GTA was the same way it's like
that day one patch baby is like you
might as well just downloaded the whole
game they put it out and the the
mandates of the publishers and and
specifically Microsoft and Sony right
and once you get that gold master and
you get you go to cert and in Microsoft
and Sony both go okay you're you're good
then it's just like okay now all this
other [ __ ]
what was it I think it was Assassin's
Creed I camera which one it wasn't Black
Flag um or maybe it was what was the was
a Brotherhood
what was the one with the first one with
Hayden Kenway that was black that I was
by playa I think it shipped with a
thousand known bugs it's nuts
but it shipped we know it's going out
again just know like in terms of the
number of bugs that you'd actually have
on a game that scale that's really not
as terrifying and the other thing is of
course off most of those will be like
ultra rare or very low importance yeah
no game-breaking bug
I can't Ken Levine was the first person
ever said to me is like it's not a bug
it's a feature this is this is a great
ad in quality that you owe you unlock
that that's right you can absolutely
ragdoll through the world absolutely
favorite one of those so stop me if I've
told this story here but my favorite
like bug that became a feature story
that I got was I was at a conference
once with some of the folks that worked
on alien isolation and they were saying
we were talking about the score of
course because the game you know it was
really well done score and they licensed
Jerry Goldsmith's music from the
original film and all this stuff I love
everything about that game and so they
had this dynamic music system where when
you would hide in the lockers with your
little radar and the alien you know
would be pinging is getting closer and
closer
had it where this nasty horror
orchestral swell would come in as the
alien got close and you lean back and
hold your breath and then if the alien
doesn't find you it would move away and
the music would slowly die data so there
would be this kind of monstrous
crescendo that you had to endure on top
of the fact that there was this alien
right outside and then one day they
realized that there was like someone was
playing the game and that musical action
happened but the alien wasn't there and
it scared the bejesus out of them and
they realized like there was a full-on
bug where the music system thought the
alien was there and it wasn't and they
were like we're keeping that and there's
a dead space [ __ ] right there nothing's
happened he was just here to scare ya
yeah I we put all the folks we gotta
quit the prototype literally I'm gonna
be very vague about this apologies but
the prototype for our next big game we
had a bug that I accidentally introduced
one morning that just basically gave a
bunch of abilities you had in the game
to you during a moment where you
shouldn't have those abilities and I had
so much fun that morning basically like
God boding that bit of the game it's
like okay well this and we actually now
put in a couple of extra weeks into
production just so we can off the pro
side just so we can get that feature
added as an actual thing with so it
doesn't look as buggy and so we can
actually kind of people it's a funny way
to talk about bugs too is the fact is
you just do something and then something
unrelated happens and you're like oh
I've added that unintentionally however
that's because of the interconnectedness
of every game system right everything is
everything is linked now and that can
lead to these kind of chaotic surprise
it's chaos theory basically like one
thing over here can butterfly effect its
way over here broken all the time I saw
this uh this picture that I should not
have been shown before I think it was
battlefield 4 came out and it was a
photo just two months before that game
shipped of the states that each levels
were in and it had red above it if it
was like completely non-functional
yellow if it was extremely buggy and
then green if they were able to ship it
and only one of them had green the rest
of it was just like red and yellow and I
was like again people talk about delays
as though the game is broken they
all broken until this sort of not and
then they still are but let's not but
that's the art that's the art of project
management in games and that's why you
know crunch is such a hot issue is that
it's the management in games is not
about our bless is not about getting it
right and having the perfect game and
then maintaining it oh I mean totally
upstage right but it's about it's not
about keeping everything perfect it's
about getting it's about predicting
realistically when the games going to
hit that level that's ok to share you
get those those calculations even
slightly off it's like navigating it's
like steering a ship if you're just like
a miniscule rotation off you're gonna
miss it by six months I thinking about
this on Twitter a little bit recently
mike is just about how important it is
for people who are project managers or
even just produces to responsibly
understand a workload and how long it is
going to take someone to do something so
that crunch can be avoided it's like I
feel like we were all pressure the
people at the top to be like make sure
your employees don't have to deal with
yes or understand the unknowns enough
that's the thing I think you have to be
really comfortable about contingencies
and and knowing that you don't know
things and allowing time for you to
you're basically allowing for yourself
to be wrong and what we've hit in a lot
of cases in game studios is it's gone
the other way where where where Studios
plan in terms of crunch they actually
have crunch built into the schedules
that they're working from so the
starting plan is that there's going to
be crunch and then if anything goes
wrong on top of that obviously that just
gets even worse yeah do you feel that
from from a being and at a studio before
multiple times I try to visit the dev as
often as I can when I'm when I'm allowed
to and I've tried to if I can go Deering
crunched as well just not rally the
troops necessarily but just I kind of
understand what all is going into making
that game and I feel if more people did
that especially on the journal side or
even just on the the player side if you
can just go through and see what what it
looks like and people I think again
there's a stigma that
like Oh crunch equals mismanagement
crunch equals lack of planning as
opposed to I did a half marathon once
and we knew at Mile 7 there was going to
be a hill like they called the dragon
because it's just it is it is a mile 7
that goes up a mountain at like a
30-degree angle and it just sucks and
you just have to get through it and
there's nothing like well we could have
made that easier it's just you're just
mile sevens just gonna suck so you like
you're talking about Mike you go in
going okay guys we know that once we hit
this point in development because
everything bottlenecks
it's like designs coming in arts coming
in animations coming in we just had to
schedule the actors everything is coming
and it's this it's this culminating
point it's not a lack of management it's
so well absenting we we we strongly
disagree on this one and I will say my
reason and I'll drop it so like the
whole way I want to see blood what
you're saying what you're saying there
about the bottleneck and about how tough
that part of the mountain is yeah that's
management management shouldn't allow
that bottleneck to occur it should be
working
they should be bulldozing that mountain
so that that's not an issue the other
really big factor here that I think is
important to note with crunch is when
you decided to do that marathon you did
it for you you didn't no one profited
from your marathon you did it because
you wanted to is your creative pursuit
it was your and that may be overstating
this but like it would be here so I love
something you want for yourself and it's
very different when you're in pursuit of
profits or someone else I work I work
ridiculous hours like but it's cool I
get to own a company and literally make
any video game I want exist that's
that's my payment for that but the
second I if I were to ask an employee to
crunch and we don't crunch my team
doesn't crunch if I were to ask that
that's not me asking them to have an
uplifting and important experience that
betters them as a person
that's me profiting from them going
through a [ __ ] experience and so you
feel it you can mitigate this directory
you can mitigate that because it's like
I kind of think you're both right in a
way because if I'm if I'm at a company
and I'm super like I can speak from
experience to you Mike about your
management style and you're the you're
the type where you know it's like you're
very conscientious of giving someone the
space and if they're not in a place to
be able to to crunch there's like a
conversation about that and then you
know assuming it's possible I see you as
the type to like say okay well then
maybe you know we're gonna have to just
find a way to bring on another person in
the eleventh hour or whatever so that
you're not crunching but then somebody
else might say look this is up to you to
kind of choose to do and maybe there's
you know there's a there's a bonus in it
for you or whatever and like it can be
managed in a way that's not so
black-and-white of this just is
inherently a failure of planning it
seems to me I say all that because I
sell that through the privilege of the
fact that composers are rarely impacted
by crunch the way the rest of the team
is because I can I can deliver
relatively sovereignly from the kind of
bottlenecks that are it's not always the
case but I'm relatively in the same way
that Troy probably is too usually I
mostly I'm mostly in the clear by the
time the hardest crunch occurs so that's
so that's where I can transition so
that's where change is where there's a
different track as well so there's
beyond just the the ethical argument
which I'm making which is you shouldn't
be treated like that by a boss the other
one that's actually more cynical is
every study available tells us crunch
doesn't work every every study that's
ever been done on people overworking if
you I think probably we all know this
from our own lives if you work past kind
of you know standard eight-hour day for
more than a week you might as well be
going to work drunk that's and that's
actually the studies have shown that
there's basically what's happened if
you're doubling up both of those oh god
mistake but like it's it's just so even
even if we were to put aside the ethical
argument even if we just say well no
it's it's not bad management the bosses
should be able to do whatever they want
and you should as long as they give
bonuses or whatever it would still be
the worst possible way of making a
videogame you are better off taking more
time or hiring more people because the
the losses you're making by having you
know Steve in the corner basically
showing up to work
every day are insurmountable and you're
not gonna arguably no one would do that
like if putting it into those terms like
this the stupidest thing you do is like
well we believe that this is part of our
culture as a studios to make sure their
one shows up drunk at least yeah yeah
well if they show off you're on a toy if
they cared about the products they'd get
drugs and government away so you feel
that you unilaterally games can avoid
crunch but Studios can avoid crunch if
they want to I think well I think I'm
would be very cautious about saying that
myself about triple-a because I
appreciate the scales are very different
I think if I think it would be possible
it but we would have to shift a lot of
how games are funded or the expectations
of production cycles I think I think the
only reason triple-a this is a horrible
truth I think the only reason Triple A
games can exist is because they go to
these extremes otherwise they would take
twice as long to make it I think there's
a commercial argument that that would
the amount of things you'd have to
change to get rid of crunch entirely
he's perhaps insurmountable where I
wouldn't presume to to know about to
know about what you would do instead
that's I think that's fair I feel that
really who is at its the cyclical
problem that we have because devs are
trying to meet the guidelines put upon
them by the publisher the publisher is
trying to meet the demands put upon them
by the consumer right but the consumers
analyzing stock market yeah true because
I am holders like I guess they have but
that's yeah that's exactly to my point
so the publishers trying to meet the
demands of their stockholders are their
shareholders to make sure that they ELLs
remain profitable they remain profitable
because people are buying their product
the product is being bought because of
and it's the cyclical thing of everyone
chasing it and then we have systems and
an infrastructure put in place that help
reinforce that like Metacritic and stuff
like that that allow people to the
consumer to really have agency in the
thumbs-up thumbs-down
of that product so
obviously it sounds like the argument
could be made that scope lacking lack of
scaling your game and scoping your game
versus crunch those two are inextricably
tied but I feel like there is this it's
all made out of fear it's or it's it's
all driven by fear because we're afraid
that this game that that people are
pinning 60 bucks
whether it be Australian UK or euro or
dollar are spending a majority of a
hefty price you know we have to give
them a return so we have to make sure
that this has multiplayer we have to
make sure that this has 90 hours of game
play even though we know we can look and
see the rate of completion of that is
going to be 10% but it's all this Jam
packing content onto that disc as
opposed to and they have a game-like
inside which is like an hour deaf to our
game or gone home or what remains of
Edith Venture journey or yeah I was
actually what's like funny you know our
game I was gonna I was gonna mention on
that subject like kind of circling back
to how this relates to delays because I
remember on journey when I was brought
on it was it was it was early 2009 and I
was told this is gonna take about a year
and a half and we shipped in March of
2012 solid solidly double the timeframe
and so there was like I think there were
two I think there were three different
six-month extensions and that was a rare
one I guess because it wasn't the
highest budget game and so the stakes
were a lot lower like to Mike's point
I'm not that's what I environment that's
what I have to acknowledge in terms of
like same way as Austin acknowledged the
privilege of like being a composer and
being outside of this process I'm in a
very unique and lucky position where a
the expectations of my games are lower
in terms of scope and scale than any of
the people were talking about and also
bluntly my stuff's well respected enough
that I get to walk into rooms and
publishers and say no we were gonna give
me this many years because my team
doesn't crunch and that's a that's
that's something that's something
that's taken a while to get to in terms
of the ability to actually have those
conversations so certainly I admire that
I because with it's one of the first
questions I'm almost always asked when
someone is thinking about hiring me is
they say how long does it take you to
write us to write a score like as if
there's just like units of score they're
like in two minutes
it said yeah and I always say I need as
much time as you have so if you if you
tell me that we're gonna ship this six
months from now that's how much I need
and if it turns out it's three years
from now because I remember what journey
those extensions like they're cues that
I wrote in the last two weeks that that
like are not quiet peripheral thing like
like like the finale of the game it
literally came in at the end and I
didn't know what to do with it you know
six months earlier than that and we've
been forced to ship I would have had to
just kind of say well here's something
and it's probably and funny enough tying
it back to the bugs conversation there
was a play test where they were they
were working on it and they weren't sure
what was working and what was not and
spoiler so there's a moment towards the
an attorney you're on this White
Mountains a snowy mountain and character
collapses in it and it all goes to pure
white and I brought a friend and to give
feedback on the game when we were maybe
about six seven months from from locking
it down and the game crashed at that
exact moment and he thought that was the
end of the game and he had like a
religious experience because of it yeah
he was like that was amazing I can't
believe it's like it's ambiguous and
it's bold and it's updation and it was
like oh actually there's kind of like a
fact that was a crash knew we weren't
monitoring his his machine he was like
in he was in Robin Hunicke office on her
computer and so she was just out in a
little common area and we were all just
kind of having a coffee while he played
the game and then he comes out like he'd
been sitting there for like 15 minutes
just digesting the experience and it
made us realize like just how weak the
end of the game is when we sent him back
into like actually finish it he was like
what that's to be just cut that because
I'll never forget for the rest of my
life weren't that fell and it really
changed that single play test altered
the trajectory and that's why for me
like delays I love delays I love the
chance to like fail more and to try
things yeah but I've never I think I
don't know I don't understand the stigma
I think it must come from this notion
that delay equals damage control because
like meaning that you're on this path
you know what it's supposed to be and
somehow you've screwed it up and you're
trying to fix it as opposed to like no
no we're still finding it we're still
writing that story as it were which is
you know you can potentially raise red
flags about about that as well from the
kind of the management of like wait
you're you're three months out and
you're still writing it but but for me
it's it's a positive for everyone in the
industry it's a positive like even for
media like it's always a oh I have more
time because there are just so many
games so when they get delayed I'm
always like oh thank god like oh my god
please push cyberpunk I really
appreciate that I remember what's the
difference between film and games we
were shadow of Manhattan Beach Studios
which is a big film stage film and we're
on stage and the next day they were like
you could walk in between sets everyone
was cool and then the next day that
stage was on lockdown and specifically
like this one little like back-alley
street that ran behind the stage that
connected our two and they're like you
can't go back there I'm like yeah we're
shooting on this stage we can go
wherever we need to go they're like you
can't shoot here it was like what's
going on and we just kind of like poked
our heads around and they were
reshooting stuff for Captain America and
I'm like is it that out like Friday and
they literally had screamed it it went
oops and said we have to do some stuff
and shot some stuff and that means that
they shot it
edited it and put it on like reals
around the world in a matter of days and
there was a response to people going I
didn't like that but well right now it's
the Marvel movies have actually now
incorporated that into their planning so
it goes back to the learning from your
mistakes thing the Marvel movies because
they have to hit these these deadlines
I'm sure the FX Ida Marvel movies
probably crunch so I'm not presenting
them as the perfect solution but they
now plan around the assumption that
they'll need to do lots of reshoots and
I've spoken to people who've kind of
been involved in some of those and like
the first version of most Marvel films
isn't great it's like a generic kind of
about as good as a superhero movie from
10 20 years ago but now what they do is
they can now because the schedule allows
for it go back and then yeah insert
those moments change those things fix it
they've basically added iteration into
the filmmaking process people talking
about how Katz has a patch
I think that's insane but I guess it
makes sense that films could now get
patched I mean we had the the coffee cup
in Game of Thrones and I guess in theory
films could get delayed I don't know
that I've heard of a movie being delayed
is that a thing that happens oh my god
the first movie that ever got doesn't
him big nerd right here first movie that
got ever got delayed for universal
artists I think it was a you a movie no
paramount obviously sure but this was we
have announced this movie it is gonna
have this street date it was supposed to
come out in this summer and he got
pushed by six months was Godfather and
one of the reasons why it was the most
expensive movie ever made because they
had to lock off New York and shoot it
and there's this crazy crazy production
schedule and there's the the history of
making of Godfather like what Marlon
Brando did to go through that whole part
of his own money
it was crazy crazy and he got paid
nothing to do Godfather
he was ousted
that point but the Robert Evans tells a
story and the kid stays in the picture
late great Bob Evans who just passed
last year sat where with with he says I
was there with Frank and and we're
screening Godfather he goes and we start
the reel and 95 minutes later the lights
come back on and he said I looked at
Francis and I said you shot an epic and
you turned in a goddamn trailer give me
the rest of my movie
so the original cut of Godfather was
like an hour and a half it was a haul of
like hour 45 minutes I got cut out and
it delayed the movie it was the first
time he said I had to go to the studio
and go we're not gonna make our street
day and they're like that's
unprecedented I think it happens all the
time now I mean wasn't rise of Skywalker
originally going to come out in the
summer when they first announced it and
then they decided we're gonna we're
gonna it wasn't I could be wrong but I
had thought that it was initially
announced to come out you know kind of
alongside like the end game and that
closer to those releases and they said
we should push it to the to the
Christmas window too many others and we
need more time yeah I guess I always
would have guessed that Star Wars was
always meant to be a Christmas movie but
yeah I don't know but for the record I'm
also on a lot of drugs so it also
happens just generally now like the
bigger studios who can afford to will
actively like choose a release date once
the films done so you have a lot of
situations where like if there's an
actor that there's a certain amount of
controversy in the press say they'll
just leave it a year before they release
the film and it's it's led to some
really weird situations with films
recently because you know obviously me
two things have happened and actors have
been kind of you know we're never going
to see that actor in a film again and
then three years later a films released
which has that actor in you're like what
happened in psycho no that was on the
shelf for four years because they
because of this other issue that was
holding it up yeah so I think it happens
way more than we know yeah
or movies that couldn't find
distribution because they were featuring
a no-name actor then that actor came out
and did something really really big he's
right and they went back and they were
like hey we want to buy this movie and
put it out it happens right awakens came
out basically every actor who was
relatively new and that Phil
all everyone who was sitting on an
independent movie that person and made
years ago released immediately yeah
there was a there was a I remember again
this could be remembering this wrong but
I was I was gonna say you take this up
perfectly Troy because I remember
hearing that you know they shot the Lord
of the Rings trilogy it was like it was
like two years of shooting or something
crazy and in the late 90s so they were
shooting this you know in the prior
decade before that film came before
fellowship came out in like 2001 or 2002
[Music]
go Mortensen had landed the gig as the
star of that Arabian horse race movie
dalgo oh yeah you know the landed that
and they had shot it and it was a
hundred percent done and then when the
Lord of the Rings snatched him up after
that they went well that's going to be
huge our movie is going to be ten times
bigger if we just wait into so they
literally sat on that movie for like
five years and then it came out vastly
later and I could be again it could be
wrong but I remember hearing that he had
shot that before the fact that then they
realized if we have anything of course I
think the hilarious thing is that it
came out and totally blocked but yeah
but you gonna stay up to date in the
horse based drama yeah to breathe so
much innovation you have to you have to
be cutting edge to love about this
podcast is we cover a wide we went
through power outages coronavirus we did
our due diligence of covering Star Wars
and we ended on Star Wars which is great
[Music]
advocate for the audience in a way that
I feel like we just didn't mention that
guys might come again we did not mention
that I do understand why consumers or
people who play video games get
frustrated by a game date being
announced and then a delay coming really
soon after and I understand the
sentiment of then why did you announce
the release date when you did and I
think that's a lot of the time to do it
with the marketing team and yelling at
Deb's it's not gonna help anyone but I
fully understand why
we'll find out frustrating especially
because I think sometimes we forget
games are expensive and people have to
budget to preorder one thing and
sometimes that's the only game that they
really get to play that whole year and
that's not that uncommon that they can
only buy one I mean in Australia won
$100 game so when you delay that game
because you've announced a release date
and you've pushed it I fully understand
why that part of it gets a lot of
criticism does it seem to everyone else
though like the audience are actually
being much more generous about that with
us like it feels like the reaction to
the last couple of delays has been a
game they love yeah like the like you
said alone I feel like people with
cyberpunk we're like oh please wait like
please please wait it's other it's other
games that maybe our new IP even though
cyberpunk is a new IP but that I've seen
people be like oh god delay I'm
heartbroken why are they doing this it's
it's games that have been proven when
they're precious about it I see but by
and large people can like support also
just getting to see developers openly
talk about that stuff on Twitter it's
probably opening people's eyes up to how
it works yeah I think I think there's
more transparency generally than there
used to be and people are more the
openness of people like you guys or or
you know I see a lot of developers that
you know I I had all this admiration oh
for the longest time I didn't know
anything about them like you know Tim
Schafer you know or even like Ron
Gilbert or like my childhood heroes and
and then you know yeah thanks to Twitter
I have a vastly greater insight into
their process and to what they're
dealing with and that sort of thing and
I feel like that has a pretty net
positive I mean obviously people can be
sort of targeted for harassment and [ __ ]
in ways that was never really possible
before if they decide they don't approve
of your delay
[Music]
whatever oz2 is good whack lets you tech
Brio ladies and gentlemen yeah no but
yeah they're I mean they're obviously
huge negatives to Twitter bakery Austin
that there are also major positives to
us being able to understand how games
walk about and I think even the
understanding that games are always
broken and they're extremely difficult
to make and I appreciate every developer
who speaks up about that stuff even if
it means you're inviting yourself to get
a lot of criticism from people who don't
really understand so I think developers
and publishers are also getting a little
more savvy about how to kind of play
that as well like I'm working on a game
that they knew there was a really good
chance of it having you know a few
months added to the schedule so
initially there was like they just
forever they announced the game and then
it was no release date announced we'll
keep you posted and then finally they
got confident enough to say it's gonna
be 2020 yeah but they knew like that
gives us a nice 12-month target window
because they because you know they've
added they've added time but they're
still absolutely within 2020 and push
came to shove if they said look it's
gonna be 2021 the only reason they would
do this to make it better so anyway you
were you were graciously taking us out I
was just really saying thanks appreciate
the the three of you for sharing your
wisdom with the world and I think that
it makes the whole industry and
community more understanding in general
so that's awesome
sorry for the technical issues everyone
if anyone who it was shout out to Troy's
dog 8-bit who appeared in frame for a
small chunk of times about he is he is
look at me like dude I have got to pee
right now so piddles in my studio yeah
we're on pretty much all of the audio
podcast services now but if anyone who's
listening has another one that they want
me to add it's pretty easy to do so let
me know it but I think I pretty much got
all the requests covered and
we will see you next month bye ray bye